it is evident that what really happens
in formulating this kind of law is that
at the outset irritability and
Sensibility constitute the organic
antithesis but this content gets lost
sight of and the antithesis deteriorates
into a formal one of quantitative
increase and decrease or a varying
intention and extension and antithesis
which no longer has anything to do with
the nature of sensibility and
irritability and no longer expresses it
hence this empty play of formulating
laws is not confined to organic moments
but can be practiced everywhere and with
everything and rests in general on a
lack of acquaintance with the logical
nature of these antithesis
in paragraph 272 Hagel is talking about
the formulation of laws were in the
German Gazette's gave him is this
activity of giving laws of setting laws
down and he sees this at least at this
point as a matter of going from the
inner to the outer for the organic being
going from the qualitative distinction
to quantitative distinctions he had he
says that this ends up becoming an empty
activity we saw him in just the previous
paragraph tracking in terms of a
tautology and tautologies are really
empty formal statements right they don't
add anything to our stock and knowledge
they don't advance at us anywhere
although they appear to be saying
something different they don't in
reality do so Hagel thinks that that's
what's happening with a lot of the
efforts to provide laws on the part of
reason on the part of reasoner's about
organic substances organic beings so he
says what really happens in and this is
at the outset irritability and
Sensibility constitute the organic
antithesis they constitute an organic
opposition and gagan Zots between the
two of them they're not the same
although they are within the same thing
we've been through all that have to
rehearse all of that go back to the
previous videos of you you want that but
what we do and here is where the problem
lies we move from that to a quantitative
way of looking at it and he says the
antithesis then deteriorates it breaks
down into a formal one of quantitative
increase and decrease or intention and
extension and the question then that we
end up having to ask and this really is
this is a good question i asked in
general for anybody who is trying to do
quantitative study observation and
LSS and say prediction or you know
generalization about qualitative things
especially about living dynamic systems
are we still talking about this stuff
anymore or have we ended up focusing
just on these numbers at a certain point
this is a familiar experience when
you're working with data the data seems
to take on not only you might say a life
of its own but to conceal what it's
supposed to be data up so the question
he asks here is a really important
question that often gets left out in
quantitative analysis does this still
Express Express what remember with the
law the outer was supposed to be the
expression of the inner hey what was he
asking this as a live question does it
still express and he's answering that
and he says this antithesis no longer
has anything to do with the nature of
sensibility and irritability notice are
you saying they're no longer he has
anything to do with the nature of sense
sensibility and irritability that
doesn't mean that it doesn't have
anything to do with it you're observing
that right but the question is whether
you've lost hold of the essence of those
things what do what happens says it no
longer that expresses it it expresses
something different it goes off on its
own tangent you might say right and then
he says this is an empty play of
formulating loss it's not confined to
organic moments why is it important
wouldn't it be nice if we could bring
everything all together under the same
law what was our goal we want to
understand the organic phenomenon as
such not to understand it merely in
terms of inorganic phenomenon we wanted
to understand what was truly distinct
about it how it was in advance and we
wanted to understand that in part
because that's what we are right this is
jumping ahead a little bit but when we
all into this we end up with something
that works in a certain sense because it
applies to everything but a no longer
gets us at the nature or the essence of
organic phenomena which require a more
qualitative approach
lastly if instead of sensibility and
irritability reproduction is brought
into relation with one or the other of
them there is no longer even the
occasion for making laws of this kind
for reproduction does not stand in an
antithetical relation to these moments
as they do to one another and since this
lawmaking is based on such an antithesis
here even the show of its being
practiced is absent
having just pointed out a problem in the
previous paragraph one of many problems
with the way too much lawmaking or
giving laws is handled by reason
observing nature hail now in section 2
73 very very short section is going to
you know get in that last dig which is a
real clincher so he says look the law
has been trying to articulate the
relation between sensibility and
irritability we've seen that there's
problems with mathema tising or
quantifying these things because we kind
of lose track of what we're doing and we
lose hold of the essence of what it is
the qualitative opposition between them
that we're trying to make sense of
there's other problems involved there as
well and that he says but in addition to
that there is more than just these two
factors or functions and what's the
relationship then between reproduction
and Sensibility reproduction and
irritability or is the other relation
between the hat and this organic yet if
this is the law that would articulate a
quantitative distinction and relation
between these two it doesn't really have
anything to say about reproduction and
you might say well that's not a probable
makeups new laws right and so we get a
lot for reproduction and maybe a walk or
relationship your that sensibility and
Hegel saying though here look I thought
you were going to give me a law
pertaining to organic beings organisms
as such not just a bunch of cobble
together laws you notice what's
happening here implicitly is the same
basic movement the same basic
questioning movement with respect to law
that occurred back in force and the
understanding if it's too specific of a
law it loses
it's law like this even though the more
specific it gets the more perhaps
quantifiable looking yet the more you
know it can focus it on those things but
if we really want it to be a law it
needs to be addressing the totality of
organic being so he says reproduction
doesn't stand in an antithetical
relation to these moments as they do to
one another they are an antithesis to
each other at least that's the way the
science of his time is understanding
these two functions reproduction isn't
in that case so this is provide us any
intelligibility to reproduction itself
and its relations with these other
functions and he says so this lawmaking
is based on such an antithesis here even
the show of its being practiced is
absent so this law is looking pretty
shabby at this point
the law-making just considered contains
the differences of the organism in their
significance as moments of its notion
and strictly speaking should be an opera
re formulation of the law but it
essentially involves this thought that
those differences you have the
significance of being already given and
the consciousness that merely observes
has moreover to confine itself only to
their outer existence the actual
organism necessarily contains such an
antithesis as is expressed by its notion
and such as can be determined as
irritability and Sensibility as these in
turn appear distinct from reproduction
the externality in which the moments of
the notion of organism are here
considered is the inner zone immediate
externality not the outer which is the
outer of the whole organism and its
shape the inner in its relation to this
is to be considered later on
Hagel is continuing this this criticism
or critique how observing reason goes
about its activity of attempting to give
laws or or formulate laws because that's
given for the the phenomena that it's
particularly interested in here which is
organic v8 organs yeah he starts out by
talking in terms that are a little bit
less than totally clear that's that's a
great thing that you could say that pie
somes everything an angle says the law
of making content contains the
differences of the organism of their
significance as moments of the notion
right we could be like the notion of
organism and strictly speaking should be
an a priori formulation of the law what
does he mean there apriori there is
coming from you know Hagel directly
operation does he mean it in the sense
of totally detached from experience well
not exactly because then it wouldn't be
involving observational but it should
have some freedom let's say from
experience so that it's not tied to any
particular experiences it should be
something that then you know observing
reason can put in its pocket and whip
out when it needs it and that apply to
things so I can actually have it
unfortunately so he says it essentially
involves this thought that those
differences have the significance of
being an already get differences between
these functions right in a consciousness
that merely observes he has more over to
confine itself only to their outer
existence now here we're going to see
some discussion of outer and inner
carried on that ties in with the you
know stuff that we've seen before so he
says the actual organism so we've got
contrasted to some notion of organism
the actual organisms the actual we're
going to is what is being observed by
reason because that's that's how it
works so the actual organism
necessarily contains such an antithesis
as is expressed by its notion now we're
going to contain that antithesis does it
contain it in what we're going to hear
call the outer hour which is just the
outer per se which is a shape the
gestalt of the organism we can oh here
we can talk in terms of the organs the
systems you know the things that we've
been we've been talking about up until
this point very good s there there we go
or are we talking about the inner but
the inner as what we can actually
observe so the elder of the inner that's
what we're getting at here yet he says
the actual organism contains such an
antithesis as expressed by its notion
and such as can be determined as your
ability and Sensibility right so there's
that antithesis and then we also have in
their reproduction which again we
haven't determined exactly how it's
related to these other two so observing
reason and observing reason was was
engaged in getting lost right giving a
lot that laws but law and handed
actually succeeded in giving a lot it
doesn't appear to so far so it says the
externality in which the moments of the
notion of organism are here considered
is the inner zone immediate externality
so it's not the the you know externality
of the external it's the externality of
the inner now the outer in which is the
outer the whole organism and as a shape
the inner in its relation is to be
considered later on so he's reserving
some some topics and he's saying that
this is what it's its activity of giving
law what it is actually looking at all
of this but not the inner itself not the
dynamic so flex ative movement that
we've seen
is intrinsic to living beings
if however the antithesis of the moments
is understood in the way it is present
in outer existence then sensibility
irritability reproduction sink to the
level of common properties which are
universality is equally and different
towards one another as our specific
gravity color hardness and so on in this
sense it may well be observed that the
organism is more sensitive or more
irritable or has a great of reproductive
capacity than another just as we may
observe that the sensibility of one is
different in kind from that of another
that one reacts differently to a given
stimulus than another for example horse
reacts reacts differently to oats them
to hate and a dog again differently to
both differences as readily observable
is that one body is harder than another
and so on but these sensuous properties
hardness color etc as also the phenomena
of response to the stimulus of oats of
irritable response to loads or have the
number and kind of young produced when
they're related to one another and
compared among themselves essentially
conflict with any conformity to a law
for what characterizes their sensuous
being is just this that they exist in
complete mutual indifference in manifest
the freedom of nature released from the
control of the notion rather than the
unity of a relation your rationally
playing up and down on the scale of
contingent magnitude between the moments
of the notion rather than exhibiting
these moments themselves
in paragraph two
75 Hagel is now following through on
this discussion focusing specifically on
the outer existence say the outer
existence of the organic da and looking
at how this activity of attempting to
impose provide sets a law by observing
reason it is going to play itself out
yeh says if the antithesis of the
moments the opposition is understood in
the way its present in outer existence
what does he mean by our existence there
the what's fully up right then
sensibility irritability and
reproduction sink to the level of common
properties and he says the problem with
this is that these become universality
that are mutually in different than
argue to read them mutually a different
to each other they're no longer in a
relation to each other now what's the
law supposed to provide us with so I'm
just supposed to provide us with the
relation between the inner and the outer
it's also sports if this is the stuff
that's in ER it's supposed to say what
is the relation between these things as
well so if they're mutually a different
to each other that's going to be a
problem for the law and thereby for
observing reason which is putting all
its eggs in that basket of the law isn't
it so he says I'm they're equally
different towards one another he has IRS
a specific gravity color or hardness
what is he talking about there he's
thinking about inorganic substances so
he's saying that you know when we look
at for example a mineral which has those
sorts of qualities those are the things
that we use to to try to make sense of
that we actually quantify those those
end up being mutually indifferent to
each other as well so he says in this
sense it may be well observed that the
organism is
more sensitive right or more irritable
then or has a greater reproductive
capacity than another just as we may
observe that the sensibility of one is
different in kind from another so for
example you know when it comes to
sensibility we know that bees see
flowers in very different ways that we
do in part because we've done all sorts
of cool experiments i don't have the
great detail about that we know that
ants you know follow Chemical trails and
will be human beings I suppose you can
say we do so to a very very limited
extent with pheromones but not not
really right so he says that you know we
can observe the sensibility of one is
different kind from that another that
one reacts differently to a given
stimulus of the mother so you know horse
he says reacts differently its oats and
to heat it also reacts differently to
you know being given a carrot or an
animal being being poked in the ribs
with spurs all sorts of things right do
I not so much in notes although maybe in
Donna cookies I don't really know I know
they're made of grains of some sort so
he says these are differences as readily
observable is that one body is harder in
another but what's the problem with that
these sensuous properties is also the
phenomenon of response to the stimulus
of loads of irritable irritable response
to loads or the number and kind of young
produced when they're related to one
another and compared amongst themselves
essentially conflict with any conformity
to a law we can generalize can't be
that's not the same thing as a law so
what is Hagel saying here he's saying
that when we're dealing with these
indifference mutually a different
qualities in terms of actual organic
beings looking at them from the outside
we don't see what turns
out to be a reliable intelligible you
know follows through and make sense out
of every case kind of pattern that we
want from them instead where have we
seen this before it looks like we're
back to where we were earlier in merely
describing things doesn't it now that we
hopefully had left behind but now it
looks like the law is not turning out to
actually be feasible which means it's
not really a law so you might say well
what was observing reason doing of these
cases and that's a legitimate question
it has been striving and it has been
learning it has not attained yet to what
it was attempting to reach but it is
Gavin to something so he says these
these centers properties and the
phenomena of response they conflicted
that a conformity to a lot why what
characterizes our sensuous being is just
this here is the upshot of this and
again this is not something that we
haven't seen before
we've talked about the freedom of nature
you know in relation to law particularly
when we're talking about you know
atmospheres Elam's or things like that
organic nature is different than
non-organic nature in that it has a
greater degree of freedom and just to
remind us we're not talking about
freedom in a very abstract sense that
people in philosophy vashon want to do
we're like only human beings are free
because only human beings to formulate
options for themselves we're not talking
about freedom in that sense higgles not
talking about freedom in that sense
which I got something more basic a
spontaneity capacity to be otherwise you
might say a contingency we're going to
talk about what this kind of freedom is
we could call it a contingency that
makes itself contingent and thereby
escapes the bounds of necessity that
seem to apply all these contingent
beings there's an agency and activity
even if it's not necessarily one that
knows exactly where it's going involved
there so he says the freedom of nature
released not just from the law but from
the control of the notion so not only do
we lack the unity of a relation which
would be that law but we even have a you
know sort of unmooring from the notion
itself and remember the notion of
organic being was what these were
supposed to be expressing involved in
taking shape baths it almost looks like
things are falling apart at this point
doesn't it so he goes anime says what do
we have here your rationale is a
beautiful metaphor here your rationally
playing up and down the scale of
contingent magnitude between the moments
of the notion rather than exhibiting
these moments themselves that is
some pretty great pros there what does
Hagel actually mean by that what we've
got is you know you might say not even a
bifurcation because I would imply to but
but a split it into these these in
different moments from each other and
each of the organic beings that we're
looking at winds up just kind of doing
its own thing things that we can observe
but now cannot bring within the scope of
irregularity so it appears appears at
this point irrational to us the very
diversity of life has been lost hold of
incense of trying to make sense of it
but it's confronting one and not just
the diversity of life and that there's
different kinds of things but the ways
in which those things are living things
can we put Humpty Dumpty back together
again that's going to be the big
question running through paragraphs yet
to come but this isn't the end by the
way of Hegel's critique of law involved
with observing reason